what we are going to try to understand
in this video
is the balance
balance of payments and it's really how
a country accounts for the different
ways that money is flowing into the
country or payments are happening into a
country or payments are happening
outside of a country and right over here
i have information for the united states
in 2011. all of the numbers right over
here are denominated in dollars and in
green i have all of the reasons why
currency or why payments would be made
to the u.s either the government of the
u.s the federal reserve of the u.s or to
citizens of the u.s and in orange i have
all the reasons why the payments would
be made to folks outside of the us
either the governments central banks or
private citizens and for this video i'm
going to first focus on the left hand
these reasons right over here and this
you could view this is the current
account the current account and the
current account focuses on things
related to trade so exports and imports
things related to income in that period
so if i'm getting dividends from a stock
that's a german company or if someone in
germany is getting dividends from a
stock it's an american company and just
transfers of money i give money to my
mom in france to help support her so
that's what's factored in in the current
account in the next video we will talk
about the capital account the capital
count which focuses
on
transfers or payments that are due to
changes in ownership of assets and we'll
see how they all balance out either in
the next video or maybe the video after
that so but let's first focus on the
current account
so in green i've had all the reasons why
the u.s got payments from the rest of
the world in 2011. so the first one
right over here is exports you could
imagine if we are exporting and this is
in billions so this is 2.1 this is 2 105
billion which is the same thing as 2.1
trillion if we're exporting 2.1 trillion
dollars worth of goods and services then
the rest of the world is going to have
to pay that much to us so this is going
to be an inflow this is going to be a
payment this is a reason why we have
more dollars after all the appropriate
currency transactions take place why
more dollars have to come to the u.s
either to u.s private citizens to the
government or to the federal reserve and
for the most part this is going to be
for private citizens or corporations
and this right over here is income that
americans get from owning assets abroad
in other countries so imagine that i i'm
an american citizen i own an apartment
complex in london the folks in london
have to pay rent on that i convert that
rent to dollars and i bring it back to
the us that would be an income receipt
to me it's the reason why currency or
payments are being made to the us and so
once again that's why i've colored these
right over here in green now let's take
let's think about the other side of that
coin obviously we're not just selling
stuff to the rest of the world the rest
of the world is selling stuff to us and
that's what imports are factoring in and
the us actually runs a trade deficit it
imports more than it exports to the tune
if we wanted a round of about 2.7
trillion dollars and once again if we're
buying other people's goods and services
we need to make payments to them
currency needs to go to them and so you
see it's to the tune and that's why i
wrote it right over here of in orange
and once again income payments other
side of income receipts this is
foreigners owning assets in the united
states if a foreigner owns a pizza
parlor in the united states
that pizza parlor makes a hundred
thousand dollars in a given year then
that and that hundred thousand dollars
will go to that foreigner it will be an
income payment and so that's what this
factors in right over here this is
income on foreign owned assets it does
not go to an american it does not go to
the american government a private
citizen a corporation or the federal
reserve it goes to someone outside of
the country and so this would be an
outflow a payment outside of the country
and so this last part right over here
this is net transfers this is literally
just on a net basis americans giving
money away to the rest of the world and
it actually since americans give away
more than they receive from the rest
world we're not talking about
transaction this is kind of just pure
you know i'm an american citizen i give
money to my mom in france or this could
even be foreign aid the us government
giving aid to a country
and since the us does give more than it
receives we just write it down on a net
transfer basis and it is it is right
over here a net outflow and so we can
figure out looking at this well just
based on these causes you know in the
the trade deficit the income receipts
and the net transfers whether the us is
transferring more currency abroad or
getting more currency on to i guess you
could say into its ownership and to do
that let's let's get our calculator out
let me get the calculator out and so
let's think okay so this is all of this
is all of the money that we are getting
these are the payments these are the
inflows to the us so let's add those up
105 billion
plus
739 billion and now let's subtract out
all of the outflows of capital or i
should say all the outflows of currency
from the u.s all of the payments that go
out of the u.s so let's subtract so the
payments we have to make due due to
imports so 2.7 trillion and then we have
the 518 billion of income that
foreigners make on u.s assets and then
finally or or foreign assets of the us
or in the us i should say and then the
money that the u.s just gives away to
the rest of the world on a net basis and
you see here when you just look at the
current account the u.s is running a
current account deficit for just these
causes alone the u.s is making more
payments than it is receiving we are
running we are it and it's running and
it's to the tune of 474 billion dollars
so let me write it right over here so
our current account
current
current account
account
deficit
deficit is to the tune i already forgot
the number
474 billion 474 billion dollars if that
number was positive i would call it our
current a current account surplus